[Music]
what shake and reject nation it's John
comin atcha happy III week I'm probably
the last person you'd expect to see
introducing III week on this channel or
any other channel for that matter but I
saw this trailer drop this afternoon and
I just was plumb excited about it so I
thought we could check it out together
and just you know a preface for the week
we're gonna be doing a good amount of
III coverage there a lot a lot of game
trailers dropping today alone between
Microsoft and Bethesda you had a whole
bunch of different trailers dropping
probably won't get to everything but
we're gonna get to some of the big stuff
some stuff you guys want to see so we
will be doing some video game coverage
you'll see me in some of the videos you
see Greg and some of the videos but I
know what you might be thinking you may
be thinking John what gives you're a
movie channel and that's true we are not
a video game channel first and foremost
but Greg and I did come up playing a
good amount of video games we both have
a lot of enthusiasm for video games I
think and he's actually been making time
lately to catch up on some I know he's
played The Last of Us
uncharted he's working his way through
Red Dead Redemption right now which
looks awesome and I just moved all my
old consoles back in so I'm looking
forward to catching up on some things
maybe starting Bioshock or something
like that we are not experts necessarily
and so throughout the week you're also
gonna be seeing a whole bunch of our
very talented very video game savvy
friends coming by lending their
knowledge lending their expertise to
y'all and you know just helping us make
these as good as they can be so keep an
eye out for that and check out all their
respective channels and whatnot share
the love but right now we're gonna hop
into Devil May Cry 5 very excited about
this games been a long time since
they've made a Devil May Cry it's like a
decade right since Devil May Cry 4 came
out oh yeah we're gonna talk about some
Devil May Cry at the moment because this
is a series of games that I actually
played I really like Devil May Cry and I
was really excited this afternoon when I
heard they dropped a new one cuz you
know whenever I'm wistfully pining for
video games this is usually one of the
titles I think of where I'm like oh it
would be really cool to get a new one of
those and yet here we are right now and
I guess this is a direct sequel to
double make cry for they did a reboot a
little while back which I heard was
pretty good it's it's the one I haven't
gotten to play any of yet but from what
I understand it was pretty good but
didn't do very well here and so it's
been kind of a low for the series since
then from what I hear this is a direct
sequel to part 4 continuing on the
original story not the alternate
timelines
I am pretty excited to see these
characters again so let's let's jump
into this we've known each other
whoa
[Music]
you never had this much
hahahaha that's rad
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh felt like an auto mouth
[Music]
that well-functioning arm to kick
demoness
it's a pretty good at killing demons I
got a 12 week walk what
no chitchat or monologue it's getting
hot
that's
[Music]
oh whoa
[Music]
oh okay I all right that's that's
exciting for a second there I didn't
know we were gonna see him or not
all right give me a sec give me a sec I
like the Nero got himself a haircut and
and now Dante looks like a platinum John
wick which is not a bad idea to me I had
a lot of fun with this trailer man I I
mean part of what drew me to these games
in the first place was this wild
mishmash of the tones here I mean I
found it through Resident Evil cuz I
guess this was supposed to be a Resident
Evil sequel that just got so different
that they were like we got to call it
something else and and you can see like
I get how we got here from Resident Evil
but yeah it's it's own thing and I've
always admired that kooky blend of
badass stylish hack and slash action
that overall gothic meets heavy metal
vibe with these literary and religious
themes pulled in different like Heaven
and Hell demonic ideas and stuff like
that with the wacky humor and the
over-the-top violence and stuff there's
like a big blood fountain in this
trailer which like totally brought me
back this is a cinematic trailer there
is some gameplay in here it does look
like but overall I mean I just love the
tone of this because it looked
appropriately angsty it looked
appropriately badass it looked
appropriately messed up because a lot of
the creatures you wind up fighting in
these games are horrible like hybrid
monstrosity I love that dude with the
big mouth belly and things like that
there's something in these games that
always feels like they're a bit of a
love letter in some way shape or form to
Evil Dead I always get a very sort of
gleeful vibe from these games Dante and
Nero are kind of like if ash was you
know a little bit more competent and a
lot more badass like ash is pretty
badass but you know like they're always
fountain one-liners and they rarely
break a sweat just all these
combinations really scratches a niche
for me and this game looks like it's
bringing all that back in full force and
the biggest difference to me is I didn't
get to play the remake game but just ten
years since definitely cry for and fee
do games have changed a ton so part of
me is just in awe of how beautiful and
crazy all these different land
escapes and all these different set
pieces look you know cuz they were
always cool before but you know just to
see them look that much more photo real
and stuff like that is really exciting
to kind of watch a game that you've
known through various iterations
throughout your life grow in something
super modern like this and he's gay he
doesn't have the devil bringer which is
a surprise and again I guess but I think
that's a cool thing to add to this I bet
you're gonna be able to switch it out
and do different combos or upgrade it in
various ways and I'm excited for what
that might add to the action I've always
had fun with these games sort of
oscillating between the different attack
styles and whatnot and I like his is
spunky southern sidekick whoever that is
his like girl in the chair you know tech
person making him autumn is she's like
Winry but but southern and that you know
that gives like you know you had Trish
in the earlier games it was kind of a
partner to Dante and then you had kiri a
who was sort of like the loevinger who's
like the Princess Peach Devil May Cry
for this little buddy relationship
they've got going on here at least in
this trailer seems like a lot of fun to
me maybe she's gonna be like your person
you're checking in with a whole lot
upgrading your auto mails and stuff and
I love that they're cruising around in
the van with the Devil May Cry logo on
the side and stuff like that you know
like a mobile shop almost and yeah just
the way this trailer starts out even
with the spooky old narration the guy
with the cigarette and you're just
seeing all these images from the ground
level like these look so cool and this
has always been a game series that I
wish I could find a way to bring to life
as a movie but video games are so much
more like movies now than they ever have
so in a sense I guess I don't need to
but someday I would like to but yeah I
mean this just looks like it has
everything I remember loving about Devil
May Cry I'm I'm curious on the flipside
being that it's been so long and video
games have progressed so much what the
gameplay style is gonna be like I mean
from the images just from the look it
seems like you're still gonna be able to
do this similar kind of very heightened
really stylish and probably not too hard
to combo with fighting style you know
switching between the sword and the
shooting you probably have like a good
lock mechanism or whatever you never
know and they have gotten a little more
sophisticated over time with some of
their combos and moves you got to
remember so I'm curious you know as
somebody who still has to kind of get
acquainted to the new age of
video games the ps4 is in the Xbox ones
of the spectrum I'm curious about just
what its gonna do to the overall world
in motion I mean the the games have
always been pretty cinematic so I don't
think it's gonna get in the way too much
I don't anticipate that from where I'm
sitting right now this looks really cool
I mean it's clearly updated to the now
but it's also building off the classic
series the curious about what the story
is going to be about overall neros got a
score to settle and that cutscene there
looked pretty intense when devil
bringers being ripped off of his body
I'm wondering who that is in the cloak I
got to imagine that's probably whoever
you're after or one of the people you're
after in this game there's some fans
speculations and comments that that
might be Virgil maybe I don't know at
this point I never expect anybody to
stay dead so who knows but yeah I mean
it's just seeing this again after so
long this looked totally badass I had a
great time just with this little trailer
alone and it made me really want to go
back and revisit the old ones and it
made me really excited to get my hands
on this one so gonna have to upgrade
some of my equipment and also you know
just looking forward to the rest of the
week here and what everybody else has up
their sleeves and whatnot just today
they announced Halo infinite Kingdom
Hearts 3 Gears of War 5 fallout 76
I guess there's gonna be a new doom in a
new Wolfenstein which is pretty exciting
to me Skyrim and Elder Scrolls are
thrown out there are new stuff so yeah
keep an eye out throughout the week
we'll be covering a whole bunch of
different stuff and we'll have a lot of
great guests on so be sure to check them
out give them some love as well thank
them for coming by but yeah let me know
what you thought hit us up down in the
comments and as always you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a reviewer videos Alex cuz why
would the subscribe button do that and
if you love us that much you can check
us out on patreon I got a whole bunch of
cool exclusives over there and yeah we
will see you on the next one Cheers
people